the solar system contains millions of
objects
from tiny meteoroids to majestic gas
giants
the largest planets in the systems are
accompanied by dozens of satellites with
saturn in the lead in terms of their
number
a big number of celestial bodies of all
sorts of chemical composition and size
are constantly looping around it
following bizarre trajectories and
interacting with each other
some of them form giant rings
which is truly a spectacular sight
however this wasn't always the case
[Music]
[Music]
approximately a hundred million years
ago
[Music]
a large icy satellite approached saturn
too closely
the gas giant's extremely powerful tidal
forces shattered it into trillions of
small bits
[Music]
so
[Music]
obeying the overwhelming physical laws
these bits gradually spread out
embracing the planet in a primary ring
it was roughly a thousand times more
massive than saturn's today's rings
[Music]
millions of years have passed since the
time of the disaster
since then some part of the destroyed
satellite's fragments were swallowed up
by saturn without a trace
other debris bombarded the surfaces of
its multiple satellites or else left the
environs of the gas giant altogether
[Music]
this is one of the most well-grounded
scientific hypotheses today that account
for the origins and evolution of
saturn's rings
[Music]
even after hundreds of years of
observations
this tremendous structure in space still
hides a lot of secrets
saturn's rings do not have a clear-cut
border
the width of their visible part is about
as much as 280 000 kilometers although
there are thinnest clusters of dust and
rarified gas beyond these borders these
structures diameter reaches 16 million
kilometers according to some estimates
although they cannot be seen from the
earth on account of their extremely low
density
in spite of the impressive dimensions
the total mass of the ring system is
quite small by space standards and is
estimated at 3 times 10 to the power of
19 kilograms
which is about 2 000 times lighter than
the moon
solid objects account for only three
percent or so of the structure's overall
volume
with a rest filled with rarefied gas and
cosmic dust
the disk surrounding saturn is
conventionally divided into several
large rings
however a rather powerful optical
telescope will reveal each of them to be
clearly made up of a large number of
thin circles separated by narrow gaps
these gaps form due to the gravitational
influence of both the planet itself and
its many satellites
some of them are as much as several
hundred kilometers wide
even though saturn's disk reflects
several times more sunlight than the gas
giant itself some rings are next to
impossible to see
for example the d-ring the closest to
the planet which consists of tiniest
water ice crystals and frozen methane
its upper border is posited to be
located sixteen thousand five hundred
kilometers above the planet's
conventional surface
as for its inner part the ring has no
clear-cut border and gradually fuses
with saturn's atmosphere
next to it is the brighter and more
massive sea ring which is approximately
17
500 kilometers wide
it is comprised of space objects
measuring up to two meters and which
make up just 0.03
of the discs overall mass
the brightest and most outstanding part
of the disc is located further and is
designated the b ring
it begins roughly 34 000 kilometers
above the surface of the gas giant and
its width reaches 25 000 kilometers
the thickness of the larger part of the
ring does not measure over 5 to 10
meters while its outer part forms a
vertical rim towering up to two and a
half kilometers high
the outermost visible ring of saturn
begins 64 000 kilometers above the
planet's surface
it is roughly 14
600 kilometers wide harboring not only
comparatively large ice bits of 10
meters and more but some satellites as
well such as pan daphnis and others
the existence of such large objects may
prove the theory of ring formation
following the destruction of the ice
satellite
alternatively they may have formed at a
later time as a result of smaller
fragments colliding and merging
beyond this part of the disk there lied
the almost unobservable f g and d rings
which formed from cosmic dust and
rarefied gas
it goes without saying that most of
saturn's large satellites actively
interact with the rings
traveling as far as
179 000 kilometers away to the region of
the so-called e-ring the celestial body
dubbed enceladus is to be found with a
diameter measuring just 500 kilometers
it does not qualify as one of the gas
giant's largest satellites but it stands
out for other reasons
the point is that enceladus is one of
the few celestial bodies in our system
where there are clear manifestations of
cryo-volcanic activity
analysis of the observed emissions
proves that there is a notion of liquid
water under its surface
mathematical modelling shows that its
temperature measures from 45 degrees
celsius below zero in the upper layers
to zero degrees at the bottom
[Music]
due to high content of dissolved salts
and ammonia the ocean does not freeze
over even in sub-zero temperatures with
the icy shield about two kilometers
thick covering and thermally insulating
it
the celestial body's surface temperature
is about 75 kelvin or
198 degrees celsius below zero
its atmosphere is extremely rarified and
is 91
water vapor
other elements making it up are nitrogen
carbon dioxide and methane
powerful geysers that erupt from time to
time through cracks in the icy crust to
the satellite regularly supply its
atmosphere with chemical elements
but the celestial body's weak gravity is
not enough to prevent the atmosphere
from floating away
the upper region of the atmosphere is
constantly losing some amount of
particles that go to sustain the earring
on the other hand enceladus constantly
captures material from the space around
it thus ensuring its peculiar chemical
balance
it is known that geyser activity of this
celestial object depends on its orbital
movement
it is likely that saturn's tidal forces
deform the satellite's icy shield
causing it to crack in multiple places
and to erupt
it is also known that the cryogenesis
emissions contain elaborate organic
molecules which may mean that the
conditions in the subsurface ocean may
hypothetically be favorable for the
genesis of biological life
also the gas giant's fifth largest and
most massive satellite tethys can be
seen approximately three hundred
thousand kilometers away from it
it is peculiar for sharing the same
orbit with two other celestial objects
telesto and calypso
they're located the so-called stable
lagrange points with telesto 60 degrees
ahead of the main satellite in its
movement along the orbit
while calypso on the contrary lags 60
degrees behind
unlike the massive spherical tethys
these celestial bodies are not that
large and are regular in shape
they measure roughly 20 to 30 kilometers
in diameter with their overall mass just
several trillion tons which is modest by
space standards
interestingly modelling shows that
calypso and telesco could not have
originally formed in the same orbit with
a more massive body following it which
means that they arrived to join it at a
much later time
as for tethys it is a celestial object
with a diameter measuring about 1060
kilometers made up of mostly water ice
with some rocky impurities in its
composition the most outstanding feature
of its relief is the giant impact crater
odysseus
its diameter measures around 450
kilometers which is about twice as small
as the diameter of tethys itself
its depth reaches as far down as three
kilometers
there is also an easily noticeable chasm
of enormous proportions on the
satellite's surface which is called the
ithaca chasma
it is as long as about thousand
kilometers
that is about a third of the celestial
body's circumference in as much as a
hundred kilometers wide
as for its depth it ranges from three
thousand to five thousand meters and the
bottom is pock-marked with a great
number of craters and minor
irregularities of the surface
according to one of the theories about
it the ithaca chasm formed as a result
of tethys's subsurface ocean freezing
over
on turning into ice the water expanded
in size and erupted through the
satellite's outer crust
another assumption about the chasm has
to do with the odysseus crater it is
thought that the impact waves traveled
across the entire surface of the
satellite and caused a powerful
resonance around its circumference
as a result tethys's crust cracked
forming this incredibly large chasm
still further from saturn there lies its
largest satellite titan
which also boasts quite a number of
highly unusual features
with a diameter measuring
5152 kilometers it is in fact the second
largest satellite in the solar system
with ganymede held in the first place
it is also remarkable for being 5.5
percent bigger than mercury
titan is also the only satellite in the
solar system with a dense atmosphere and
bodies of liquid on its surface
since titan lies quite far from the sun
the temperature of the celestial body is
quite low at around 94 kelvin or 180
degrees celsius below zero
having said that in spite of its
comparatively small mass titan is
capable of sustaining an atmosphere
which is one and a half times denser
than that of the earth
nitrogen accounts for over 98 of the
atmosphere's chemical composition with
methane and other gases making up the
rest
exposed to solar wind nitrogen and
hydrocarbon compounds in the
atmosphere's upper layers transform into
more complex organic substances which
subsequently slowly settle on titan's
surface
due to the impermeable hydrocarbon smog
the satellite surface is unobservable in
the optical range
according to the most plausible model of
titan's inner structure there is a
massive rocky core at its center
with a diameter measuring about 3
400 kilometers
it is embedded in a thick layer of
exceptionally dense ice
which forms the bottom of a cool salty
ocean containing up to 10 percent of
dissolved ammonia
it is buried under a crust of water ice
mixed with methane hydrate which is many
kilometers thick
in temperatures as low as that
the ice has properties identical to
those of a solid substance and forms
mountain ridges and elevations on the
surface
as for lowlands and chasms they are
filled with lakes of liquid ethane and
other hydrocarbons
solar wind and saturn's extremely
powerful magnetic field constantly strip
titan of its atmosphere however its
internal processes keep replenishing it
so the process of losing it may take
billions upon billions of years
when the sun hits the red giant phase it
will be capable of vaporizing
hydrocarbon haze and melt the eternal
ices and titan
after this the satellite will become a
more favorable place for the genesis of
life
however
it will not happen for a while yet
of course saturn's system does not end
there it contains dozens upon dozens of
truly exciting objects
and occasionally delights us with new
discoveries
for example one more satellite was
discovered in 2009 which lay extremely
close to its planet
and in 2019 astronomers introduced the
world to about 20 small celestial
objects at once which orbit the gas
giant
the more we study the universe the more
overwhelming is the impression that
there are likely billions of systems out
there which are not less elaborate and
mysterious than this one and there is
still no way to know what we will see
when we finally get to observe
them dear friends
due to a few reasons we're not posting
new videos as often as we would
naturally prefer
that is why to always keep in touch with
you we are starting a series of short
one-minute films in our telegram these
are short informative videos both about
the solar system objects and remote
corners of our universe
join our space community and we
meanwhile we'll get on with our work and
we'll soon start posting new videos for
you to enjoy
let's keep in touch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you